alors hidalgo maire bis en tout cas lors
d'un meeting dans l'arrondissement où
elle est élue le 15e d'airtran delanoë a
accordé à sa première adjointe une place
de choix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas demain se débrouille elle a du
caractère je vous dirais la d'autorité
mais elle est toujours d'une douceur et
donc je sais qu'elle est meilleure que
moi bertrand delanoë à qui vous avez
succédé et avec qui vous avez rompu à
moins que ce ne soit le contraire qu
est-ce que s'est il passé entre eux non
non moi j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour
bertrand il m'a aussi fait confiance
j'ai lu aussi c'est une école de
l'exigence dans cette ville de paris où
j'ai tout appris il m'a donné cette
chance que j'ai saisi aussi de
comprendre de travailler en profondeur
13 ans 13 ans 1re adjointe à être à ses
côtés à le défendre tout le temps parce
qu'il a été aussi très attaquées et à
apprendre
cette cette vie d'élu cette vie
politique par quelque chose de très
concret aussi ensuite en 2017 il a fait
un choix un choix pour la présidentielle
d'ailleurs chacun vaque ronde et
emmanuel macron voilà c'est un choix que
je respecte et puis on voit là on s'est
vu un peu moins chacun a pris un chemin
j'ai été éloigné aujourd'hui on ne se
voit pas tous les jours ça c'est clair
mais je garde de toute façon pour lui
immense affection et un immense respect
quels que soient les choix respectifs
qu'on ait pu faire
[Musique]